the Supreme Court hears arguments this
morning in a high stakes case on boating
laws now many analysts say the outcome
could potentially quote damage American
democracy Chief legal correspondent
that's Jan Crawford is outside the
Supreme Court Jan the fact that it's
gone to the Supreme Court means this is
a very big deal but explain what this
case is really all about good morning
Gail I mean this is an important case
about election oversight and
redistricting but it is not as some
commentators have suggested some back
doorway for state legislatures to try to
steal a presidential election that is
overblown now this case came about when
Republicans who are in control in the
legislature there in North Carolina Drew
up a canoe Congressional map that was
extremely favorable to them it would
likely flip the number of seats from
democratic to Republicans so the
Democrats challenge that and the state
supreme court which is majority Democrat
throughout the Republican Maps as two
partisan so the Republicans then decided
they're going to pull out this novel new
Theory that's called the independent
state legislature Theory and that says
that the U.S Constitution gives State
legislatures the sole authority to set
the quote time places and manner of
holding Congressional elections and the
state courts don't have a say in that
now if North Carolina wins on that
argument it would really sap the power
of state courts to review state election
rules or Congressional Maps but it would
not affect other challenges like
challenges based on race those are heard
in federal courts and it also would mean
that state legislatures could somehow
try to substitute a new slate of
electors after election day to try to
steal a presidential election even if
they tried there are federal laws that
would prohibit that Nate
Jan thank you